all right that's the main cause
guys that's dear better get on with the
starter gentlemen good evening that's me
tom nice to see you max tristan tristan
hi harry you four are a bunch of old
etonians yeah and all of you think
you've got what it takes to
work in my kitchen god help me okay tom
what's on the menu tonight
tonight we're gonna do a crab spring
roll with some chili dipping sauce
um and then off that we're going to do a
venison pan fried with some
too stoked uh
yeah we're not just cooking one table
here we're cooking 14. okay
don't let me down and more importantly
don't let yourselves down okay guys
on all the fight covers table 11 5 crap
spring roll five venison
five profiterole yes sir no [ __ ]
no forgive me i was not listening to the
first yeah well [ __ ] off max and wake up
okay max come here come here
max and tom come over i put this one
together quickly
what's in there harry run me through it
again quick uh we got crab obviously we
got sweet corn we've got coriander we've
got spring onions we've got the lime
pepper on the stove here sorry thank you
don't worry i'm only here
okay yes sir a tablespoon of grain
mustard
right let's roll one together shall we a
little bit of seasoning on there yes
and then make a nice sort of almost like
a sausage
shape yeah just one third in
up over nice and tight and just pull
back
press down your end's there tom yes sir
you look like you used to roll these
kind of things except we're going to fry
this one not smoke this one yes
okay yes yes a little bit of egg white
and roll
nice all right come on guys let's go hey
first table
okay let's dress the salad shall we i
need to do another one that didn't work
that's fine
your hands are shaking like mad watch
that's the customer there facing you
okay come on let's go
yeah all right would you do you pay for
them yes or no come on yeah yeah good go
please table five go
quick right that's the first table out
there yes far too [ __ ] slow
yes now we know what we're doing can we
work as a bit of a team yeah
so far your [ __ ] let's go
unbelievable this has to be the hardest
day of work these guys ever seen in
their entire [ __ ] life
i work for an asset management company
i'm
in financial services that's why you're
here
i have a bit of an income from a share
portfolio that my dad created for me
i love eating out i love going out for
dinner managing oreo into a hotel
it's been a good night out when i spent
less than 100 pounds
we all went to school when we were 12
years old to a school called easton
college and since then we've known each
other ever since i love cooking because
um
the artistic side of it getting your
hands really messy quite like to have
like a starter of
cheeses with like a fish fondue for main
course i love
fish it's expensive i love adding my own
ginosequa we're going to sell 150 plates
though it's as simple as that we know
we're going to win
on order four covers table one four cups
being rolled for venison four for fitter
roll
okay now uh it's really important you
don't [ __ ] around if i find you're
joking and pissing around
i'd rather just [ __ ] off home okay
because all i've seen so far is this
sort of jumped up little six-year-old
wants to play with his dick concentrate
what you're doing
get it right we'll have the [ __ ] fun
after it so laughing joking in front of
them you're gonna look stupid
okay yeah chef come on guys please come
on come on come on come on this is
this is beyond [ __ ] slow i'm just
checking in before you start rolling it
taste it okay because what you're
tasting is what the customer's tasting
yes
we can't work this though guys yeah sure
yeah if you're this slow at clara just
yes
we're gonna be [ __ ] do you know that
huh there's nine tables left to send
it's embarrassing
come on just move your arse [ __ ]
hello my darling hello how are you
thank you for that yes now you have to
be my ideal guest perfect oh why oh you
just love your food
i do passionate yeah i am now who cooks
at home
we both do lenny is in charge of meat
right and i'm in charge of virtually
everything else
really meaning vegetables and sauces and
things like that he's cooking uh the
most amazing sunday night she's got a
leg of lamb
and i am busy flitting about yeah doing
all the other stuff and saying when is
the meat going to be ready
yeah and he lies about when it's going
to be ready he lies
he says yes yeah he's coming it's coming
he's coming i was very
a bag of boons by the time i got the
first class and you had that
amazing setup of comic relief where you
exploited the sort of most handsome men
across the planet
yeah yes in terms of um smogging them
yes yes
george clooney brad pitt johnny depp
yeah uh i
frankly draw men to my lips like
a magnet who's who's next on the hit
list
um well it's not you gordon
um
handsome people you've got something on
your lit now oh
it was actually my lips oh
no no no no no no no that was a nice one
it's really good to see you know thank
you and you are an amazing
kisser good to see you see you later
yesterday
who was that the
flavors in the sauce and in the sprinkle
themselves uh
ouch on anything i've had to do with
crabapple
couldn't taste the crab meat now in
amongst the seasoning of the mustard
and unfortunately once i put it in a
dipping sauce it just was pure salt
i've never had cornish crab and so it
was really nice to try something
different
right okay results we've started yes
out of 50 guests yes
only 25 of them are paying yeah
why sir um too slow too slow clearly fat
or slow
yep uh too much moisture there's one did
you taste it have you mixed it
uh probably every time no every time you
make a new mix you taste it
not good not good at all nah but why
don't you try and put it back for the
main course yeah and get 50 out of 50
customers paying
for the venison let's go guys yeah
next on the menu i get called out to a
fast food emergency
it's like you just changed the [ __ ]
babies
dawn french helps me in my search for
the next fanny craddock
would you be interested in my fanny
and i head to norwegian lapland to catch
giant killer crabs
my balls feel like two big [ __ ] ice
cubes
welcome back to the f word now time for
the main course loin of venison with
sweet sour peppers and broccoli rabe
lorna venison one of my favorite meats
slightly gamey
absolutely delicious it's packed with
protein low in cholesterol and so it's
like the rolls-royce cut
it's phenomenal i'll cut it into four
marinade olive oil salt
pepper thyme is a very sort of dainty
soft
sweet herb and it goes brilliantly with
the rich gaminess of the venison
juniper berries the flavor is almost
like a
sort of rich bittersweet slightly
peppery flavour
garlic get the back of your knife on it
get the loin place it on top olive oil
season
leave that to marinade and that's ready
for the pan
cooking the venison you've got to be a
lot more delicate than you were if
you're cooking a fillet of beef because
it's very lean hardly any fat on there
hot pan olive oil
keep on rolling it around should become
nice and springy and slightly bouncy
and that indicates that it's slightly
pink but a little bit firm in the center
butter baste the venison
and then just take it out of the pan and
just spoon it over there
leave that to sit now for the sauce
we're gonna do a really nice sweet and
sour pepper
red and yellow pepper just stand the
pepper
up on its base and just cut around like
we're segmenting an orange and look
you've got the seeds there fit for the
bin
olive oil in peppers into the pan a
little bit of salt
and by having the skin on the peppers it
doesn't allow the peppers to become too
soft and overcooked it keeps them
really nice and robust thyme this is
where it gets really exciting
white wine vinegar smells amazing but
it starts to glaze the peppers i cut the
tablespoons of water in there
you've got this really nice sweet and
sour peppery
vinaigrette at the bottom peppers out
carved nice thick slices
and look the juice is coming out the
peppers a little bit of
salt just glaze the venison with some
extra virgin olive oil
and there look venison with sweet and
sour peppers
done okay listen
i'm gonna ask you for the last time to
stop laughing i'll just take this next
[ __ ] half hour really seriously
yes let's go yes let's go
right there we go 30 seconds in harry's
pissing his pants
okay five venison harry yes chef
let's go let's go
right in gotta get hot
yeah nice and hot keep playing i asked
for five venison in you've got four in
there
sorry chef oh dear oh dear get some
butter in there please
no in there you've remembered nothing
okay got a lot of information oh [ __ ]
off all those [ __ ] school fees i
can't [ __ ] absorb jack [ __ ]
the excuses you guys have come out with
they're [ __ ] hilarious
come on let's go hurry your pan's on
fire
stop what you're doing put the pan down
turn the gas off first
holy [ __ ] take the venison out holy [ __ ]
really important not to get too much
color on the venison it's a delicate
meat
very lean and it dries out if it's too
dark come on guys
tristan what are you doing
they're burnt no they're a kid do you
think i'm here to [ __ ]
massage your ego their birth i wouldn't
come into your world and tell you what
to do
they're [ __ ] burnt me chef could i
ask
how much broccoli pepper
and toffee okay yeah come on let's go
mashed potatoes on
come here please tom yes yeah you you
chase them
that's kind of fun
i thought you cooked a wreck of lamb
last night i did check but this is
venison
i don't want to take these out if
they're not ready i love your [ __ ]
arrogance you know that i've never met
someone so [ __ ]
full of [ __ ] in all my life corny is
answering you back he's not arrogant
and you can answer me back we're in the
[ __ ] we've got nothing to answer back
about
no one's [ __ ] losing an opinion every
time i tell you something it's like
[ __ ] bite back bite back
what i do want is 50 customers served
that's what i want my kitchen my [ __ ]
rules
uh so far you're the strong i need some
[ __ ] help right now everyone wants to
[ __ ] argue and [ __ ]
piss around all i want is a customer
that's nicely cooked let's go on there
like that let's go
it's olive oil let's go
time to kill some giant crabs
they're big they're ugly and they're
coming together it's the invasion of the
monster king crab
king crab is the largest crustacean in
the world and they're heading for
britain
norway has a massive problem with these
huge giant king crabs
they're just breeding and breeding and
breeding reducing the fish stocks
and causing a huge problem all the king
crab that come to england
are frozen so i'm now going to catch one
kill one
and see what it actually tastes like
fresh from the sea
two flights and eight hours later i
landed kirk and s where i met my local
crab hunter
lars peter oy welcome to northern oregon
thank you yeah very happy to be here
never been this far up
it's [ __ ] freezing here there's only
one way to get around in norwegian
lapland and it's not my car
we're heading over the mountains and
down to the frozen fjord which is where
the crabs hang out
unbelievable you get like a child again
you know yeah that was extraordinary
good to see you
50 000 crabs live under this ice and if
you want to catch one
we're gonna have to dive down beneath it
did you ever try ice diving i've never
been nice diving i've done lots of
diving but
it's a special kind of diving and you
need the special skills but uh
we will try now don't make the hole too
small i want to get out easy just in
case those [ __ ] things are huge
will we stay completely dry hopefully
yeah
so i've never dived in a dry suit before
that's one leg
there's not any water get in there is
that feel like a big [ __ ] condom
at least you're very safe oh god bloody
condom
oh that was hard work though yeah
right ice diving can be extremely
dangerous as it's so easy to get
disorientated in the freezing dark water
i'm [ __ ] myself
when you fetch a crab you should just
grab one of the legs
the claws are very strong so they can
snap your finger and even uh
yeah more so if i'm swimming over one
yeah watch out for my widget yeah it's
gonna be cold down there it'll be frozen
i don't know what it snapped off
okay
[ __ ] me it's freezing oh [ __ ] my [ __ ]
boots
we could get hypothermia if we stay down
too long so we've got to be quick but
that's easier said than done
i can see the crabs but i can't see the
surface
these freakish beasts grow up to six
foot wide and have no natural predators
so it's down to us to bring their
invasion
under control
so
a lot harder than i thought it would be
yeah the size of the thing
good sizing and look at her beautiful
my balls feel like two big [ __ ] ice
cubes
laza showed me how to catch a giant crab
now i'm going to show him a new way to
eat it
but first i've got to kill it okay yeah
yeah then it's dead actually now it's
bleeding out yep
yep we cut off the legs and boil them in
seawater for 15 minutes
discarding the body which isn't that
good to eat
because the quality of the king crab is
so delicious it doesn't
need much more no so i'm just going to
do something very very simple with the
creme fresh mayonnaise
and some tarragon and some lime okay
i'm making the sauce by mixing equal
amounts of mayonnaise and creme fraiche
with some lime zest
salt and pepper roughly chopped tarragon
and freshly squeezed lime juice
delicious
nice lovely you can try to to break the
main joint here and
if you're lucky keep it whole
the meat will come out like this lovely
it's the size of a lobster tail isn't it
now look at that that
smells and looks amazing this
is what i've been waiting for
beautiful
that's delicious my god i actually now
think i prefer it
lobster so much softer and sweeter
is there any more what do i have to go
back down and get another one
maybe you have to go down again okay now
i'm pregnant
right what do you think of the venison i
liked it very much the texture was
fantastic it melted in your mouth
really good i quite liked how crispy it
was on the outside
um do you get a chance to watch food
programs on telly um i do a bit
uh-huh but i i to be honest too many men
uh there is the sort of saint denia of
these worlds
yes there is dania fantastic yeah but
let's be honest
she does seem a little less steady on
her feet nowadays yes ready
there is nothing wrong with that delia
is passionate
lots of people think delia are very
controlled is passionate and she's
passionate about football but if a man
was passionate about football you'd be
going yes
that was a difference
the reason why i'm sort of concerned
about the dealers of this world is the
fact that we've got no one else coming
through
no that's right no young ones coming
through i knew the younger ones
yeah have a quick look at this oh
bless fabulous hair look at that
yeah then you add
a little tawny port i'm not going to
explain to you why now it'll be quite
clear to you in a moment
move that candle will you johnny love
this worth a ton
thank you to me who did you support
didn't you of course
one small wine glass full of tawny poor
that's all right then
she was ahead of the time she's
knowledgeable and she was she was out
there
yes i'm gonna search high and low to
find a
talented female that's good enough to
fill the shoes of funny credit
and then finally get her own slot on the
f words i need somebody with triple a
fanny factor unique discipline tenacious
and some of them love beating the cup
out there for this top top fanny right
andy
all we have to do okay is visit the
website and log on get details
and send me a three minute segment of
their
fanny credit action funny videos
is that what you're actually asking
people to send in
show me that they can cook talk
understand
and they've got a lucid funny factor yes
okay
would you be interested in my fanny
i can't wait for you to find this person
yeah i can't wait it's right time
yeah yeah okay all right gordon one last
place
no i just thought the mate was
absolutely stunning it was well cooked
it was well seasoned
and um i'm never gonna eat venison again
because i don't think that can be
surpassed
it took a very long time for it to come
to be honest i think that would
put me off pain it tastes really nice i
don't think the peppers are that
sweet and sour but they taste very good
okay result of the main course come over
tom please yeah okay tom
i think we did 50s 50
okay the dining room decided to pay for
34 out of 15 main courses
that means 16 refused to pay why um
mainly the meat was right the meat was
dry yeah i'd like to think that i
stopped all that stuff going out so i
think that's a little bit harsh in terms
of 16 yeah not agreeing to pay for it
i listen it's not perfect but it's a
comeback
on the back of the starters yes yes okay
so now dessert
50 out of 50. okay let's go
next on the menu i take on natasha
kaplinsky the recipe challenge
would you prefer the bottom
and janet street porter sings her teeth
into prince charles
caramelized sugar sugar
welcome back the f word now time for the
recipe challenge when i take on a
celebrity
and beat them at their favorite dish
ready yeah awesome recipe family recipe
the kaplinsky carrot cake
well this is my father's recipe and it's
a it's a kaplinsky tradition that yes
you are
accepted into the kamlinsky household
you get a carrot cake made for you
lovely now when was the last time you
made it um i've made about nine in the
last two days
you're joking seriously it's the first
for me you know that
i don't believe that no i'm serious
trust me the first time you've baked a
carrot
first time okay in 11 years i've made a
camera then you'll have beginner's luck
well fingers crossed right okay so i'm
going to sift my dark brown sugar first
yes
that makes a nice sort of smooth center
so it's not too lumpy
what are you doing i'm putting my flat
all my dry ingredients going in first
actually
right two teaspoons of cinnamon you must
get a lot of attention outside
the newsroom yes you do get the
occasional in fact i've got this one
chap at the moment who seems to
every time he misses the news he sends
me a bouquet of flowers but i don't
think he realizes that i can't actually
see that he's not there yeah
just sipped in my brown flower my mixed
spice
and bicarbonate soda fold that in to the
oil the eggs
and now i'm just gonna add the carrot
grated the zest of an orange
and the zest of a lemon it's really
important to keep the carrot fairly wet
that gives it really nice
carrot flavor i have mixed all the dry
ingredients
in one bowl and all the wet ingredients
in the oven um and then basically you
mix
both of those together add some carrots
nuts raisins
dates and then that's the carrot cake
and now that you've invited me very
politely into your yes this is a big
initiation
okay if i just quickly give your father
a call
okay hello hi it's gordon ramsay i've
got natasha in the kitchen here
and she's cooking your amazing carrot
cake oh yeah
but have you any tips in there i'm
lacking confidence dad you're looking
confident i think
a cracker would yeah right your dad said
move your ass
i look forward to joining your family
now that i've been sort of brought in
and sort of
given the cake sadly there is a bit of
bad news if she does lose she's going to
start blaming you you're aware of that
aren't you i took that for granted have
a nice evening
does that make you feel better yes it
does yeah i'm feeling okay now
are you ready for the other yes yes off
we go
would you prefer the bottom i'm not
gonna answer that question well you're
obviously on the top aren't you
right it's a fact good food doesn't have
to be slow food
i'm fed up with people eating junk and
using the excuse that they're too busy
to cook
so every week i'm gonna prove how little
time you need to create a delicious
healthy meal
this week's six rapid response nurses on
a hectic 10-hour night shift
for them being fast is critical but
their diet is seriously slowing them
down
if we could learn to cook something
quick easy something healthy and
nutritious
energy yeah right we wouldn't be a
supersonic nurse oh yeah
no stopping us
how long has that been around i mean
it's older than fanny credit we've never
used it no we don't
oh my god so freeze is jam-packed
yeah yeah with [ __ ] how did you manage
how did you get through your day
we've got a garage bottle garage
microchips micro junk
you're being too much like women you're
caring for everybody by yourselves
challenge you go down to the garage yeah
right
buy one portion of your frozen food
yeah come back cook it
okay and by the time you've cooked it
and put on the plate
i would have had six portions of
something simple
fast delicious with these two girls
doing it
okay are you ready yeah you're gonna
jump in your car you're ready don't
speak am i ready
i was born ready
the nurses spent 25 minutes every night
buying [ __ ] food from their local garage
i am convinced i can teach them to cook
something much tastier
sticky lemon chicken set with champ and
green beans
we'll leave the skin on because i'm
gonna get some color on the chicken that
music color
means flavor
time fresh thyme potatoes ready
time how are we doing for time
for two ladies at rapid response nurses
there's nothing rapid about your cooking
would you mind just taking my pods i've
been in here now eight minutes and
you're driving around the [ __ ] bend
actually it's pretty impressive is that
so it's not high
it's good
okay i won't think madame is now
thinking he's on the way back
cream and milk up to the boil yeah and
start stirring there you go good
oh she's here she's here joanne oh [ __ ]
that was quick
in the microwave already i don't wanna
hear that [ __ ] being a little bit of
pep on there
joanne your beans jesus christ right
place the beans around the outside put
the pan down how long please
missy microwave 12 12.
sticky chicken with lemon and green
beans finished
look at that very nice yes show me show
me the evidence
on the plate please oh let's see it's
like you've just changed the [ __ ]
baby's [ __ ] napping
yeah i got too much respect for your
[ __ ] job for you to sit and eat that
i'm living sorry no chance
fast food yeah it doesn't need to be
complicated you know
ah chicken local supermarket a little
bit of honey promise me something
yeah we're gonna do this again yeah i'm
gonna cook it again
i'll help you to cook but i'm not
staying through the whole [ __ ] night
okay guys let's go as you leave
lift up the piping bag right finger in
and just put it on top of that little
point there yeah that stops the point
from burning
right time for dessert for fiddler rolls
with chantilly cream and chocolate sauce
for fitter rolls throwback to the 80s
something that we've all forgotten about
how to make the perfect shoe pastry
first and foremost important turn the
oven on
125 mils of milk 200 ml of water
in to the pan it's important that we
bring it to the boil
slowly butter caster sugar
salt it stops it from becoming over
sweet and
gives a really nice sort of rustic
flavor to it off the heat
150 grams of plain flour vigorously
fold that flour in back onto the heat
like that look beautiful just hanging
off the spoon
cool eggs it's really important you put
the eggs
in one at a time therefore you get this
really nice
incorporation of the white and the yolk
look
beautiful piping bag one nice lump
and look just coming through there she
is there greaseproof paper
stop them from sticking to the tray down
push and twist away
perfect now finger into a bowl of water
and just push down those little pointy
bars
this stops with it all from burning into
the oven
18 to 20 minutes chocolate sauce we use
between sort of 60 and 70 percent pure
cherry
the better the chocolate the better the
sauce simple as that
and the secret now is to melt this
chocolate over a pan of simmering water
that will melt within three to four
minutes butter
honey just look now that's beautiful
smooth
and just this wonderful texture there
take it off the heat
and that that looks perfect milk
out creme chantilly basically a really
nice flavored cream
icing sugar vanilla
and then mix it
nice piping bag
push in fit a roll generously fill up to
see the
cream bouncing back at you and just
stick them together lovely
icing sugar chocolate sauce
into a jug
buffet rolls with chocolate sauce and
chantelle cream done
come on guys the customers are waiting
yes come on and the secret of using
fresh minted of course
it's a thousand times more exciting than
vanilla extract and the flavor
is extraordinary yes yes chef
you're a possible you should always be
using fresh cheese
yeah good now i use that for my caster
sugar afterwards there you go good
all right guys start playing up two
break away play it up two back up please
let's go
okay quickly i'll break away let's go
come on
fight please yes chocolate leaves
right a question four four of you yes
while storm french was waiting for her
main course yes
yeah her and the table played shag or
died which one do you think won
the horn dawn has definitely got the
horn
tom it was really cool what do you think
lenny would think of that
congrats right
be afraid the teeth are back and the
voice
fast food i hate it a big mac will never
pass my lips i'm a food snob there you
are i've said it
now i've always associated salt and
sugar
with dreadful common fast food
until now when prince charles allegedly
called for mcdonald's to be banned
the press claimed that his very own
dutchy originals range was
even worse than mcdonald's but do people
believe
it so if you had a choice between a big
mac
and a dutchy originals organic pie which
one do you think is the healthiest i
think this one
if i said to you you could have a big
mac or a dutch european big macs
never ever okay i'm far too healthy for
that i would probably say the pie
touch the originals yeah i'm confused
and what to find out for myself what
duchy food is really like
i'm going to dutchy supersize me and for
the next 10 days eat exclusively from
prince charles organic range
so let's get the sausages on the go a
couple of rashes the bacon
well chutney you'd like to do instead of
tomato sauce
oh that is so sweet so now i'm going to
eat this for breakfast every day
fresh tomato soup with rosemary organic
parsley organic
sugar what's sugar doing in soup
sugar what's sugar doing in my cornish
pasty
fresh gravy obviously for people who
don't cook [ __ ] gravy
raw cane sugar caramelized sugar
there's no sugar in my chicken and
mushroom pie i can't eat it
i can't face it i mean my body is a
temple
i can't stomach the thought of another
nine days of duchy nosh
so i'm handing the challenge over to two
younger fitter identical twins
to make things more interesting i'm
putting lisa on the mcdonald's diet
can i have a bacon egg and cheese bagel
please
well julie is chuffed that she gets to
choose from the posh duchy range
the twins will be attempting the diets
for 10 days
during which time they'll be closely
monitored by a doctor
now i ate opacity and then i discovered
that there's more
fat saturated fat in that pasty than
there is in a big mac
this does contribute around 90 percent
of the guideline daily amount of
saturated fat
for an adult woman that's an incredibly
large amount
a duchy's cornish pasty contains as much
saturated fat as
four ginster's scotch egg bars or three
rustlers microwave bbq ribs sandwiches
or one and a quarter tesco's micro donna
kebabs
unlike me the twins managed to stick
with their menus for 10 days
what i want to know is how has the royal
regime measured up to mcdonald's
it was time to find out what effect it
had had on their health
well really the key thing is the
cholesterol now it's
the same sort of news for both of you
the percentage of good cholesterol
that you've got has absolutely dropped
like a stone oh really
so the ratio of good cholesterol to bad
cholesterol is
now in the range that would be
potentially dangerous long-term
in fact the cholesterol ratio of the
twin on the duchy's diet had changed
even more than her sisters
if she continued eating her royal regime
it could have had some unexpected
side effects lost concentration loss of
libido
loss of to tell libido
all we can say is that in this little
experiment that we've done
with you too it has had a profound
effect on your cholesterol yeah
right so i've [ __ ] up your sex life
you can't remember anything you kept
putting your phone in the fridge
otherwise okay i see all of that in a
nutshell really janet
i do feel bad about it pretty shocking
stuff
but when i tried to talk to prince
charles about it he passed it on to
duchess who said
duchy's originals are designed to be
enjoyed as part of a balanced diet
all our products use pure and natural
ingredients with no artificial
ingredients or flavors
they clearly state the ingredients and
nutritional content on the packets
we are considering adding nutritional
information on our website
not good enough charlie i've decided
to issue my very own f word
asbo to prince charles for anti-social
food behaviour prince charles this is
what you've got to do
stop adding sugar to your savory
products
stop making products with high levels of
saturated fat
and finally start giving your customers
a full nutritional breakdown of all your
products
i took charles's asbo to his mansion on
the mao
but he didn't answer the door there you
go charlie there's your ass bow
hello what's that you've got there this
is a special pie duchy pie how are you
fine considering i had tweaked that
stuff 10 days
no i lasted one day and you know the
reason why i lasted one day on the dutch
original dart nothing to do with my
loathing of the monarchy
no nothing to do with the fact i
couldn't give a toss whether i'd get a
night or not
unlike you honestly yes thank you i ate
that food
for one day and i felt unbelievably
awful
pretty sweet it's really sweet why is
the pineapple why is that i got sugar in
it
i make a chicken pie i don't put sugar
in it do you put a chili
out pasty that was a real [ __ ] body
bloke i can't believe you're capacity
not very janet
you know what if he doesn't do what i've
asked he has both
i'm gonna go back to clarendon's house
and i'm gonna post his bloody pies
through the letterbox
next on the menu i breed my own lamb
i've come to wales
for a shag and i'll find out who beats
who
in the recipe challenge and the winner
is the winner is
welcome back to the f work now here's
the news natasha you're about to lose
the recipe challenge ready to finish yes
yes serve it up i'd love to know what
you do with your icing because i've
always struggled i've used philadelphia
at some stage that's exactly what i've
used
nothing wrong with it whatsoever okay
i've gone for a mascarpone one this time
round so i don't know whether or not
that's going to work
i'm right a piping hot palette knife
just gets a really nice thin
icing and inside the icing we've got
full fat cream cheese
a little bit of melted butter and some
fresh vanilla seeds
madam yes what
no honestly it's fine it's all in the
taste right all
i can say is i've tried you tried very
well now okay should we slice a portion
no i'm gonna knock it off along nine
huh jb gently gently gently gently
gently
dish number one in dish number two
you can taste the uh the cinnamon in
that one
christmassy yeah it's quite heavy as
well i think
let's try the next one
taste citrus fruit tonight it's
definitely sweet
lemon icing or something isn't it
completely different taster isn't it
it's like it's quite syrupy as well
isn't it
okay deliver the news yes the good news
what do they think they don't need to
know
um they love it you know what this time
there is a clear winner
right yeah come on yeah and the winner
is
the winner is cool yeah yeah
well done well done my darling actually
yes really good to see you thank you so
much for coming on
now now one more thing yes don't tell me
please
[ __ ] about my kitchen now here's a
recipe for baby lamb
one meal yes
last year i brought up two piglets trini
and susanna and they made damn fine
eating
this year i'm taking homestead farming
to a new level
i'm going to breed my very own lamb i've
come to wales
home of the best lamb in the world just
3 million people and 9 million sheep
no wonder they're known as a nation of
sheep lovers
welcome to wales big day today
i've come to wales for a shag
i'm visiting an award-winning farmer
whose family have been rearing sheep for
generations
mate hello gordon how are you well yeah
what about thank you good to see you
may has exactly what i need to
crossbreed my f-word lambs loads of
beautiful welsh mountain use
he also has a selection of pedigree
french charolais rams
these are ideal as it's a big breed and
will give my lambs extra bulk
so these are these are thoroughbreds i
mean these are yeah these are yep
yep french french red yes christ they do
look french
so what were we looking for in terms of
i mean obviously a big pair of bollocks
yeah you need a bit of strength really
yeah he looks quite oldy woldy
stern yes he's four year old he's he's
had plenty of experience that one are
they friendly
oh they're fairly friendly well they're
french
is that normal for the bollocks to drag
down like that that big yes it is yeah
we'll have to check one really to see if
he is checking his bullets yeah to see
if he's fit to work what would you mean
well you can feel they've got to be the
same size really balls
yes yes i'll let you this is where you
come in i'm not going to start jumping
on their bollocks
sorry i'm going to [ __ ] draw the line
[ __ ] you now they're massive
absolutely massive jesus christ
they're hot the balls i mean they're
like piping hot yeah you must be ready
for work
[ __ ] you now huh
so this is called jean baptist i've
named him john baptist
time to get your rocks off my man yeah
jean-baptiste is going in with may's
welsh mountain ewes these are one of the
finest breeds in the world
and produce meat with a phenomenal
amount of flavor
come on giant why is he doing that with
his teeth he's showing off a bit ears
showing his presence
typical john baptiste always [ __ ]
flaunting it
and for him to lick it like that is that
normal yeah
come on drunk baptiste ali get those
balls swinging come on
there he goes
quick so quick man yeah it is yeah
and he could sort of you know ejaculate
in that short period of time
yes yes yeah oh he's having a second
chance
john baptiste
[ __ ] french what is it with them
jean-baptiste shagging left right and
center
i branded the first two use he covered
in five months they'll give birth my
very own f-word lambs
that will come home and live with me in
london
bringing these two breeds you know
together it's going to be
quite an interesting journey from chef's
point of view in terms of you know
looking at them both individually having
tasted them individually and now
combining them
um is going to be fascinating
is that absolutely your girl's leg it's
not any ordinary profiterole is it
no it's kind of an extraordinary one
all right guys come on please yes right
starters yes
yeah 25 out of 50. yeah [ __ ] stuff
yeah main course 34.
you pulled it back 34 out of 50. now
good
dessert well
you did [ __ ] well yeah 46 out of 50
customers
guys that means the grand total of 105
out of 150 yes
what scares me about that is the thought
of you for
cooking a clown yeah
well done right do me a favor
get to [ __ ] out my kitchen don't check
your share prices